- Welcome back and once again
a huge salute to all our
veterans in the audience
and those watching at home.
Our next guest served in
the Army for nine years
before launching a huge, successful career
as a country music artist,
and he continues to be huge supporter
of service men and women raising
money and doing USO tours.
He has a new album out called "Enlisted"
featuring duets with a
number of performers,
including Blake Shelton
and I'm just kidding,
and Lainey Wilson, and now
performing "Almost Home"
featuring Jelly Roll, give it
up for Craig Morgan everybody.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Thank you so much!
(bright country music)
♪ He had plastic bags
wrapped 'round his shoes ♪
♪ He was covered with the evening news ♪
♪ Had a pair of old wool
socks on his hands ♪
♪ Bank sign was flashing five below ♪
♪ It was freezing rain an' spittin' snow ♪
♪ He was curled up behind
some garbage cans ♪
♪ I was afraid that he was dead ♪
♪ I gave him a gentle shake ♪
♪ When he opened up his eyes ♪
♪ I said, old man are you okay ♪
What'd he say Jelly?
♪ Just climbed out of a cottonwood tree ♪
♪ I was runnin' from some honey bees ♪
- Grand Ole Opry!
♪ Drip dryin' in the summer breeze ♪
♪ After jumpin' into Calico creek ♪
♪ I was walkin' down an old dirt road ♪
♪ Past a field of hay
that had just been mowed ♪
♪ Man I wish you'd just left me alone ♪
♪ 'Cause I was almost home ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
♪ He said, I just comin' round the barn ♪
♪ 'Bout the time he grabbed my arm ♪
♪ When I heard momma
holler, son hurry up ♪
♪ I was close enough for my own nose ♪
♪ To smell fresh cobbler on the stove ♪
♪ And I saw daddy loadin' up the truck ♪
♪ Cane poles on the tailgate ♪
♪ Bobbers blowin' in the wind ♪
♪ Since July of '55 ♪
♪ That's as close as I've been ♪
- Yeah!
- Talk to 'em Craig.
♪ I just climbed out
of a cottonwood tree ♪
♪ I was runnin' from some honey bees ♪
♪ Drip dryin' in the summer breeze ♪
♪ After jumpin' into Calico creek ♪
♪ I was walkin' down an old dirt road ♪
♪ Past a field of hay
that had just been mowed ♪
♪ Man I wish you'd just left me alone ♪
♪ 'Cause I was almost home ♪
♪ I said, Old man you're
gonna freeze to death ♪
♪ Let me drive you to the mission ♪
♪ He said, Boy if you'd left me alone ♪
♪ Right now I'd be fishin' ♪
- Craig Morgan everybody!
(audience cheering and applauding)
♪ I just climbed out
of a cottonwood tree ♪
♪ I was runnin' from some honey bees ♪
♪ Drip dryin' in the summer breeze ♪
♪ After jumpin' into Calico creek ♪
♪ I was walkin' down an old dirt road ♪
♪ Past a field of hay
that had just been mowed ♪
♪ Man I wish you'd just left me alone ♪
♪ 'Cause I was almost home ♪
♪ Almost home ♪
♪ Man I wish you'd just left me alone ♪
♪ 'Cause I was almost home ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- All right everybody,
one more time for Craig
Morgan and Jelly Roll.
Craig's new album "Enlisted"
is out now we'll be right back-